hello everyone and welcome to a really
wonderful game from yesterday's round
eight of the European Championship it's
Austrian Grandmaster a 24 year old
Valentin Dragon versus the legend
himself vasel evanchook and this game is
really weird
um uh one of the players resigns in a
position where you really should not
resign or maybe maybe you should resign
maybe it's just so complicated that even
an engine doesn't understand it you
should resign but
you're gonna see what I mean by this uh
after a few moves so Valentin has the
white pieces and he opens with E4 we
have Knight Pawn to see five Knight F3
we have D6 and now D4 going for the
Sicilian Defense and also yesterday you
guys some of you guys got really worked
up about me saying that um uh E4 c5d4 is
the Smith Mora Gambit obviously yeah
after captures you have to play C3 for
it to be the Smith Morgan but it's just
that when I make videos I use um
chess.com's opening Explorer and as soon
as as you hit E4 C5 and D for the
opening Explorer says that is the Smith
Mora Gambit so it wasn't like a wave
that I was trying to deceive you or
anything I just it seems that I I trust
the opening Explorer too much uh so uh
so sorry about that uh but I I can see
that a lot of you
um were very hurt in the comments so
yeah it should have definitely checked
that that twice but getting back to the
game uh C captures and the fortnite
captures with Knight to F6 Knight to C3
and A6 fossil goes for the uh Knight of
variation of the Sicilian with Bishop to
E3 by Valentin uh the English attack
against the Knight respond to E5 and now
Knight to F3 the other Retreats are also
possible you could also go back to E2 to
see it at the B3 uh Knight to F3 here we
have Queen to C7 and now Bishop to E2 so
all very standard stuff Bishop E7 we
have Pawn to A4 uh preparing to grab
more space with Ponte A5 uh Bishop to E6
and now uh castles by Valentin Knight
b37 7. Knight to G5 and now there is a
game where castles was played here we
have Bishop to C4 by Russell and it is
now as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game so here A4 A5
grabbing more space on the queen side
castles and now Bishop captures on C4 uh
recaptures we have rooked A4 now
attacking the black queen queen back to
C6 we have Knight back to F3 and now
Rook 8 to C8 and this is a very good
setup for bike because now the Knight
cannot move uh as the C2 to two Pawn
will hang we have Queen to D3 preparing
to bring the other Rook into the game
Rook after d8 and now Rook to D1
so it's a pretty standard Sicilian
position uh where a black is controlling
the Knight you cannot move it and the
white is really controlling that D5
square and here we have Ponte H6 and now
Pawn to H3 and uh Chucky goes for Knight
to f8 now if you uh it really makes
it's hard to say if it makes sense but
knife to C5 it's very easy to understand
why one would want to play such a move
you attack the the queen and the rook
and now you force uh Bishop captures on
C5 and if Pawn captures okay now you
have to move the queen queen E2 now you
trade Queen and you win the D file for
the black Rook now it's not spectacular
black still has the the the the the the
weak C5 and the week E5 pawns but it is
possible to play this however similar
thing has happened in the game night to
a f8 with knights the H for now going
after that F5 Square Queen to D7 and now
Pawn to B3 now the Knight can move you
don't have to worry about the Rook
hanging Knight the six and now Knight to
F5 we have Bishop to f8 now controlling
the Knight as best as possible because
you you you really should worry about
some sort of a king side attack
Happening Here uh and now Knight the D5
now it's possible to play this as the C2
Pawn is not hanging so Knight captures e
captures and knights the C5 we get a
similar position to what we've discussed
Bishop captures you have to take uh Rook
captures on C5 now and Rook to E1 and
here we have Pawn to G6 uh also it's
possible to just play Queen to C7 it
seems that uh Chucky uh didn't realize
that he could just win a pawn here but
okay you do win a pawn but you will
allow an attack because it's very easy
for The Rook to get into the attack the
other Rook is coming into the attack the
queen is coming into the attack so maybe
uh he just decided that it's not worth
grabbing a pawn he played G6 attacks the
Knight Rook to G4 now pins the G Pawn
we've Rook the and now Rook the E3 also
uh it was uh maybe just B4 here uh I
know I always say that B4 is very
important but here you you really should
play it because uh your A5 Pawn will no
longer be hanging you don't waste time
uh for B4 because you also attacked the
rook and there's nothing to worry about
so uh throwing in B4 here does make
sense but here we have Rook to E3 and
now comes Rook C back the C8 and this is
um
uh just uh deciding to leave the pawn
alone capturing the pawn does seem like
a good idea but then look at this
something like Rook eat the G3 uh and
even if Rook day one check King to H2
and E4 just giving back the this point
to uh stop the attack at least for a
little bit let's say root captures Rook
captures Queen captures and King to H7
it's still not very pleasant the Knight
will come to D4 and now look at this
bishop G7 Knight to E6 and it's uh not
easy to withstand this attack if
captures an E6 real captors and now
threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries if Bishop E5 check you can
play Rook the G3 opening up a discovery
if King day trade even Pawn to F4 kicks
away the bishop Bishop owns D captures
on E6 and it's just a very very annoying
position to to have with black only
perfect play will will save you from uh
from losing this game so instead uh go
he goes back Rook back to C8 and now we
have Knight G3 it's hard to say whether
you should keep the Knight there or or
maybe try something else but he decides
a a to re-maneuver the Knight Bishop G7
Knight to E2 Ponte H5 and now Rook back
to A4 we have Pawn to F5 now now it's a
vasel who goes for the attack Queen back
to D1 and now Bishop to H6 attacks The
Rook Rook to G3 and now just King to H7
we have pawned to C4 and now Rook the C5
uh Rook to A2 and now Queen to d8 you
have to defend the
uh or rather you you have to go after
the A5 pawn and the white has the
defended Queen to E1 with Ponte H4 now
uh that makes this uh Rook uh uh move
from such an active Square Rook to D3
and now Pawn to E4 we have Rogue back to
D1 and now even Pawn to E3 so it seems
like a vasel's attack is really uh
coming through Ponte F3 and now Pawn to
B5 with a capture some B6 Alpha Song
Queen captures and now Rook to A3
defending the pawn not the most active
Square for The Rook but you have to you
have to do something uh although you
would much rather play something like
Rook to beat you but then you have to
worry through characters and C4 is an
option uh so maybe a passive square like
A3 is better so Bishop to G5 here now
the bishop is being re-maneuvered over
to this diagonal Rook D to E1 uh Rook D
to A1 doubling up on the a file and now
Bishop to F6 going after the Rook here
uh maybe safer was just a 5 and then if
white captures you can just trade for
example captures captures and then pick
up the B3 Pawn but in the game I've also
decided to play Bishop F6 he attacked
The Rook but now just Rook captures on
A6 uh Queen captures on B3 and now Rook
captures and D6 sacrificing The Exchange
on A1 you don't have to do this you
could also just play Rook to B1 attack
the queen and only when the queen
captures now play Rook captures on D6
which does make it uh a bit hard for
black to defend because you don't have
any pawns uh on the seventh rank also
the the back rank is open for attack so
it would be hard like Bishop t7 seems to
be the only only move that holds but
even this look at this Rook to D7 you
have to move the king Rook to B6 it
doesn't seem like a position that's very
easy to hold here the bishop always has
to keep an ndh for Pawn because then the
queen comes into the game uh very very
hard to hold but in the game Rook
captures and D6 was played he sacrificed
exchange Bishop captures an A1 we have
Queen captures and now Rook the C7
taking care of the seventh rank so yeah
you don't get checked uh Queen to F6 is
not threatening Queen captures and G6
and The Rook the G7 defending we have
Queen captures an H4 which check King to
G8 and now Rook the d8 forcing a trade
because you don't have time for anything
else otherwise Rook captures on d8 and
E8 so real characters on d8 Queen
captures with track King to H7 and now
Queen to H4 with check King to G8 and
here it almost seemed like there was
going to be a repetition King H7 Queen
page for checking to G8 but now comes
King to H2 Valentin wants to continue
the game and he wants to push this uh
for a win even though he's down the
exchange he does have the two connected
pass pawns and the vassal's past e-pawn
is nicely blockaded by the Knight so
Queen D1 uh whistle goes after the
Knight Queen back to d8 with check King
H7 Queen to F6 now
a very tricky move because what do you
play here it seems like you could
capture the Knight and then it's uh and
then it's just a draw uh for example
Queen captures here and then you really
don't have anything better Queen page
for checking the Jade Queen the d8 with
checking th7 and now you just uh well
force a draw uh but in the game Queen
the B3 was played and now comes Queen to
D4 and it was in this position on move
55 that vasley vanchuk resigned in the
game uh as there seems to be nothing
more to be done here but it's actually
not that uh not that bad of a position
uh here he resigned but uh just in case
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find even if there wasn't what
would you play here with black and how
would you survive this position well
I'll give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh spotting this
incredible defensive idea and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is rooked this sorry Rook to D7 if
any of you found this move you are an
incredibly strong player even if you you
don't think you are and even if your
rating doesn't reflect you you
definitely have potential uh to become
one now in order to understand Rook the
D7 and uh also one thing uh very
important here in the position where
evanchuk resigned uh the Valentin had
some five minutes and the clock muscle
had over 30 minutes on the clock so also
something uh very important to consider
because he could have spent more time
analyzing this I I don't know how how
much time he actually spent here before
he resigned uh but the problem is if you
play something like Queen to C2 which
seems like the way to go because you go
after the night it doesn't really work
Knight F4 and now if Ponte E2 just 96
you threaten Checkmate and now let's say
you play Rook F7 now comes Knight the G5
check and it's still not it's not it's
not completely lost I mean you can still
you do have the two connected pass pawns
but now Queen E3 goes after check and
then you want to capture The Rook Rook
let's say Rook the B7 Now Pawn to C5 and
now it does seem like you will not be
able to stop those pawns and you you
never have time to play E1 it it's just
uh very tricky to play this but that's
not really the point the point is after
this uh a knight to the E6 move you will
not play Rook to F7 the only move to
actually hold is like Rook the B7 but
even then it's insufficient The Rook the
H4 check King to G8 and now Queen to H6
with check you go after the pawn here
and now you cannot defend because if
Pawn to F4 which makes sense you guard
the G6 Pawn just a nice checking H7 and
Knight the G5 will be Checkmate and the
other thing if one to G5 which uh sort
of creates an Escape Route for the king
now you just play Queen captures and G5
King H7 and pawn to F4 and now after E1
Queen it seems like okay now black has
two queens and The Rook it's still
completely winning for White Queen to H5
checking to G8 now you play Queen to G6
with check you cannot um block with the
rookie Rook to G7 uh you can just
capture so you have to play King h8 it's
the only other move now Queen to E8 with
Chuck King to H7 and now the beautiful
Knight to G5 check will win the queen on
E1 so you're gonna have to move King H6
Queen captures Sunny one and not white
is just uh up to too many pawns Queen
captures here you're gonna play Queen D6
tracking G7 Queen characters and F5 four
pawns uh up uh of course that's uh much
better than having a rook for a knight
so that's why it doesn't work and that's
probably why vasel resigned and he
thought that none of the positions uh
that occur are even possible to play a
rather you know let alone hold the the
problem is after Rook to D7 the move
that vassal probably moved in his
calculation there's not all that much to
try here for white I've uh I I wanted to
make sure because I know how strong
vassel is and I know how strong his
intuition is and a lot of times if you
just ask the engine vassal will be
stronger than an engine so I allowed the
engine to Crunch the numbers up until
depth like 50 55 and it still decided
that the the position is a draw so
either a vassal is that much stronger
than an engine and he could see a force
to win here for white or we simply have
to trust the the engine but the problem
is now after Rook to D7 the Knight F4
idea no longer works this only works if
the queen moves away from the B file
here you can just block with Queen to B8
and now there's no good way to continue
if you go back with the King then you
just have a nice Perpetual with queen
bee to check Queen day to check and you
continue checking the white king if you
play G3 then you've opened up the second
rank and now it really doesn't matter
now let's say just Queen to A7 you offer
a queen trade if you trade Queens it's a
draw so white will have to play
something and then just Queen the A2
with check and
there's just no good way to play this
even the C4 Pawn might might fall so uh
it's not uh not possible to play it like
this so what you would have to do after
Rook to D7 there's only one line that
allows the whites to sort of have an
edge uh and that is
six uh that's the point you can't play
Pawn to C5 also by Rook the D7 is so
strong because uh it guards uh you it
guards from C5 the the D5 Pawn will fall
so here you have to play D6 but now
comes Queen A2 goes after the Knight and
now Pawn to C5 the only line that works
for white now Queen characters on E2 C6
the two connected
um uh pass pawns are of course much
stronger than the Rook so you have to
give up The Rook Queen captures and now
Queen to C4 you open up uh now the
possibility of advancing the E Pawn to
becoming a queen queen to E7 with check
it doesn't matter if you push black just
pushes so here you can play Queen E7
check to sort of control lde file but it
doesn't matter you're gonna move the
king king h8 and now it doesn't matter
how you play this I've tried it many
different different ways basically
you're gonna have to trade and it always
ends up like this doesn't matter which
way you you try uh you will always end
up with three against two and uh it's
just gonna be very very hard to try and
push this for a win because after this
uh check let's say King to G8 there's no
no good way to do this the queen after
capturing and C6 also guards the G6 pawn
and the queen alone cannot threaten the
black king yes it's up upon and yes
Stein it said once that the Queen's end
games if you're up upon you're winning
the game but here when they're on the
same side of the board it's just not
gonna be be possible at some point you
will have to advance that g-pawn and
that will just allow black to also start
checking you and they're they're just no
way to to actually win this of course
you can push this and the chances are
your oppon will make a mistake and you
actually will win the game but with
perfect play and that's not really the
case so that's why I really wondered
after Queen to D4 on move 55 did vastly
vanchuk resign the game because this is
truly lost or because he just didn't
find Rook to D7 uh it's uh I I guess
we'll never know because we I mean we
all know how strong muscle is uh so
there you have it make your own
conclusion about this one especially
since he was up so much uh on the clock
it just made it seems like a a very
premature resignation
uh but yeah that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it uh a lot of very cool
cool lines here especially this final
position I would like to thank uh Lobo
ration reptiles YouTube Joe Wilders and
Ryan Kavanaugh for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing uh to check up on you
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World like the
European individual Championship so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day